on se demande jusqu'où ce président
bavard va détruire la fonction
présidentielle
quand il parle de vous en dix ans les
petits de gaulle lapin duracell c'est la
fonction de président qu'ils s'allient
ou c'est vous qui les seuils de salière
diantre vous parler de scandale
il faut ramener tout ça à sa juste
raison qu'à plusieurs reprises il se
plaint du fait qu'il dise des choses aux
journalistes que ce soit retranscrit
dans les journaux alors parfois de
manière déformée
parfois il dit c'était of parfois il dit
je pensais quand même pas que ça allait
être écrit donc en fait ne peut pas
s'empêcher qu'on voit maintenant quelle
est la personnalité de françois hollande
un homme qui n'aime que lui-même à rabat
il est en difficulté ça je l'avais pas
éliminé en 16es qui lui-même se met dans
cette difficulté il s'est pas facilité
la tâche aux réseaux libres c'est des
entretiens avec des journalistes
avec je le crois l'objectif de faire en
quelque sorte aussi un bilan de tout ce
qui s'est passé
génération qui te feront ce qui est
vraiment une faute et une trahison
lourde à l'égard du peuple français
c'est de s'apercevoir qu'en réalité ils
savent et lui il sait il sait les
problèmes que pose l'immigration
j'en appelle à la dignité à la pudeur
les divisions éloigne les français de
leurs dirigeants par celui qui est
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'est françois hollande est je le
rappelle au service de la nation ou
nathan mon appel du québec répond
cessions de dire qu'il est persuadé que
françois hollande se représentera en
2012 sans même vous aussi vous pensez
que vous montez ce que dit nicolas mas
est ce que vous le connaissant comme je
ne connais et surprise entre paris
millions de personnes ne savent plus où
elles en sont et que quand on leur dit
la gauche
ils entendent hollandais gens n'ont pas
envie et quand on leur dit la tra la
droite
ils ont vu les sept de l'eau thouars ils
n'ont pas envie non plus non
un candidat nous expliquer qu'il allait
supprimer 500 mille fonctionnaires dont
300 millions pour le jeu c'est lourd au
nouveau parc débat était un débat
d'experts comptables il n'y avait aucune
grande vision qui émergeait de ce débat
non la politique n'est pas une carrière
au bout de 30 35 40 ans on arrive aux
plus hautes fonctions
la politique est un engagement total le
renouveau c'est comme la nouvelle usine
c'est bien au début mais on reste sur sa
solennité droit habité et émotion les
maîtres mots de cette série un texte qui
évoque la résistance qui brandit la
force de l'amour contre celle des armes
je veux être utile
christian estrosi perd son procès contre
le rappeur infinite qui avait chanté je
n'ai aucun diplôme comme christian
estrosi
je vous dis non cette entreprise
maléfique échoué à l'unité la liberté
l'humanité
au bout du compte prévaudront christian
estrosi n'a fait aucun procès à sarkozy
dj sarko qui pourtant l'avait qualifié
d'abrutis ayant une noisette dans la
tête